new pics from the Elvis impersonator who
married sophie Turner and Joe Jonas last
night after the Billboard Music Awards
in Las Vegas a selfie with Sophie and
Joe and their ring top wedding rings a
group shot of the newlyweds Vegas Elvis
and the Joe Broz and their marriage
certificate a source tells et Joe and
Sophie are a couple that loves to have
fun and live in the moment and that's
exactly what getting hitched in Vegas
was the couple does plan to have a more
formal wedding with their family and
friends but this ceremony was just fun
Joe and Sophie are planning to get
married in Paris later this year
[Music]
[Music]
with this ring
the pair got hitched late Wednesday
night at a Vegas wedding chapel dan +
Shay performed as Sophie walked down the
aisle in a white silk jumpsuit and veil
with a light-up bouquet of white roses
[Music]
josè bros Nick and Kevin stood by him at
the altar while Diplo Khalid and a few
other famous faces filled the room for
the nuptials et caught up with Sofie
ahead of the wedding last month where
she gushed over her soon-to-be husband
it's just like the best support the best
person to calm me down and keep me calm
and if I end up crying I have a shoulder
to cry on so it's good I'm so happy